welcome to the villages they call it
disneyland for the elderly here
manicured greens beach
tennis a class or club
for everyone but it's not all exactly
pleasant though
and there's a warning sign for donald
trump
once reliable elderly voters
turning out for his rival why do you
think that's happening
i think that the animosity between the
left and right has gone
way beyond limits i think there's no
no way we can ever talk to each other
anymore the
idea of sitting down and have a
conversation is no longer here
ginny insists the new threat is small
this is trump's territory you know we
have
600 700 golf cart parades for trump
and then two weeks later a hundred show
up for biden
and they're doing riding with biden
because they can't do the trump train
down the road though they're very
different to you
who's gonna vote for joe biden
one two three four five six and how many
for trump
oh so biden has it you wear your heart
on your golf cart here and sometimes
at a cost you get yelled at you get
cussed out
why can't you see yourself voting for
trump
i just don't like the man i don't trust
him he's a bigot
he's a bully and i don't like bullies
how big is the pandemic do you think in
people's destiny
he did not react to the pandemic well
this is a pretty big mountain for
democrats to climb and the majority of
people you
speak to here think donald trump will
win locally
but what's surprising is the number you
hear from
that think he could also lose the
election
but hispanic voters are also key while
trump has been rallying cubans biden's
been focused on puerto ricans in places
like
kissimmee you know i think that a lot of
a lot of minorities will vote for biden
not necessarily because they agree with
his policies or him or the democratic
party
but just to get trump out of office you
think it will be different to 2016
yeah i hope so
[Laughter]
i hope so because it's been rough
however extreme florida can look the
margins
are nearly always razor thin
cordelia lynch sky news florida